foreign
[Music]
I used to have this mean critical voice
in my head
but I committed to my recovery and I got
better
but sometimes I wonder if that voice is
what got me here
are you ready oh yes
I certainly am I
hi I'm Sheila D Rubin let's move you are
a national television personality now
we're building a place for women to be
free of judgment we should offer
meditation yoga Pottery lesbians yes
what we're brainstorming there's no bad
ideas yes
we are on the precipice of something big
there's just one problem
[Music]
Kelly kilmartin she beat you to the
bunch she's the most famous Fitness star
I'm better than you
[Music]
oh no they're looking at you she's in my
head same bigot scrutiny
she's big and a liar every time I think
you have hit bottom you've managed to
sink even lower this is really starting
to scare me you don't want to slow down
now do you get so close to the top I was
hoping it wouldn't come to this just
kidding I was dying for it to come to
this it's got time this is more than
just a business for me this is my life I
built this I am Body by Sheila
we were just hanging on by a fridge just
waiting for that moment to snap I
thought you were on a healing Journey
we have put everything on the line what
if it doesn't work
I won't let that happen
[Music]
isn't one of the steps in your recovery
Integrity recovery's a long road
[Music]